ira stoll let me start with you I heard
the mayor Mayor Bloomberg on local news
last night saying and calming people
down and saying in essence that he's
more concerned about the half-marathon
that's taking place and it's disruption
for traffic than he is about disruptions
to the city for the convention I've got
two New Yorkers here people around the
country are watching all this news
coming out of the city seeing
televisions coverage of the preparations
what's it really like living here right
now well there's a Quinnipiac poll out
late last week that showed that showed
10% of New Yorkers were getting out of
town another ten percent we're going to
join in the protests and fifty percent
said they were worried about the
convention so I think some of that worry
relates to the fear of a terrorist
attack some of it relates to fear that
the protests may get out of hand some of
it may just relate to traffic issues and
people are annoyed that it's going to be
more difficult to get around town
there'll be some street closings around
Madison Square Garden but the mayor has
been taking a different approach from
the mayor of Boston who told everyone to
get out of town for the the Democratic
convention take a vacation he's been
mayor bloomberg has been telling people
to just go about their business and has
been claiming that if you're not right
around Madison Square Garden you may not
even know the convention is in town well
let me move from your reporting hat
which is reporting on the polls to your
personal experiences in New Yorker
what's it been like I haven't really
seen anything different other than maybe
a few more police around the city maybe
the city is a little bit cleaner than it
usually is but you know I think people
are girding for Sunday which will be a
big protest by United for peace and
justice and then Monday when the
convention program actually starts going
through Thursday when President Bush
arrives and you know the nation's
attention will really be focused on us
matt taibbi as i mentioned earlier as a
columnist for the new york press which
is an alternative newspaper here in the
city your job is translating this for
your readers so what is what do you
seeing that you want to tell them about
well we haven't seen anything
yet because nothing has really happened
yet the only real incidents so far was
the thing that was on the cover of was
the post or the daily news yesterday
with the naked protester testers can I
get protesters which is one and a in a
rash of naked protest that's going to
happen this week for some reason a lot
of the protesting groups feel that
showing their underwear to the cameras
is a really important way of expressing
themselves maybe they read the weather
reports it's scheduled to be 90 degrees
with ninety percent humidity this
exactly yeah but so far you haven't felt
any disruptions it doesn't feel any
different in midtown to you I mean
there's incipient anointment is what
most people are feeling most people are
that I know are trying to get out of
town if they possibly can not because
they're worried about terrorist attack
but just because the whole thing is so
irritating our two guests will be with
us for 45 minutes to an open up our
phone lines the phone numbers of been
beneath me on the screen and we're going
to talk national politics and you're
most welcome to join in we've got some
of the New York newspapers here and
Washington Post and a little bit from
the Washington Times this morning since
we're out of our home base and we're
welcome welcoming your participation
with calls or questions on party
politics and the national issues that
are framing the debate this year let me
ask both of you to tell our audience
about your newspapers let me start with
you mr. tabby the New York Press is an
alternative newspaper it's more it was
one of the first free weeklies in the
country and well that's been around I
think about 16 or 17 years it was
originally actually a paper like more
like the Sun it was a conservative
alternative weekly but that changed a
few years ago with a change in ownership
so it's it's it's a competitor to the
village voice and you know we tend to
take an alternative view on most policy
when do you publish every Tuesday and
what's your estimated readership about
150,000 and what is your column like
what do you try to do with it I'm a
humorist basically I write a lot about
national politics but i try to do make
it a little bit more creative and a
little bit funnier right a little bit
about the national media that's that's
sort of more might be and how to get
into the business
well it's sort of a family business but
I was I lived overseas for a long time
and when I was just out of college I
started doing stringing in Russia and I
stayed over there and worked as a
reporter there for 10 years what do you
mean by family business my father is a
reporter on NBC and ira stoll tell our
viewers about the New York Sun please
the New York Sun is a still pretty new
daily broadsheet newspaper here in New
York it's got a center-right political
outlook it's got very strong arts and
culture coverage we started publishing
April sixteenth 2002 and we took the
name of an old New York Daily the New
York Sun which was published from 1833
to nineteen fifty who's your ownership
I'm one of the owners and there's a
group of New York City businessmen and
one newspaper company that are backing
the paper and how's it going so far it's
going really well actually we've got a
paid circulation of about fifty thousand
which is ahead of our plans and actually
this coming week is going to be our best
week so far in advertising I think a lot
of people are coming in who want to
reach these Republican delegates coming
in town do you does your byline up here
in the paper I not to it not in the
weekend edition but I write a lot of the
unsigned editorials and I edit a lot of
the stories in the paper let's go to
calls jemon and we'll come back and look
more website in the papers say let's
begin with a call from loser and
Michigan a supporter of Senator Kerry
good morning you're on the air loser in
Michigan go ahead please okay I'm not
hearing the telephone call we're
listening your telephone calls this
morning let me give the phone numbers
while we're patching this one end to us
it's 202 737 triple zero one if you're a
supporter of President Bush if your
supporter of Senator Kerry 202 737
triple zero two and if you're an
independent the number is 20 26 280 205
let's try southgate Michigan good
morning everybody may I read some of
your articles and I really enjoy them
now my question for both of you
is I know your reporters and you are
allowed to opinion eight in your columns
but I like your opinion Matt
specifically on this drum beat is it are
you Matt with the dark hair or is the
other fellow Matt the other Jennifer
classes yes exactly a direct okay okay
New York Press you know is what do you
think about this drumbeat of doom and
gloom coming out by the right wing press
that the Democrats are going to be
blamed if any anything turns violent
when these protesters the majority all
of them really have absolutely no
connection to the Democratic Party
whatsoever this seems like another ploy
similar to the Swift Boat Liars for Bush
that you know we're all going to get
blamed for anything that happens in New
York because the Republicans cynically
picked it so close to the 911
anniversary thank you thanks very much
yeah I mean obviously I think the the
propaganda that's coming out about the
the mayhem that's going to happen this
weekend is mostly totally irresponsible
and I'm actually surprised it's not more
of an issue in fact I it was either
yesterday or a day before that in the
Yaak which is ed gillespie's Republican
National Committee online magazine they
actually warned that the Democrats are
going to be planting prostitutes with
AIDS in the in the crowd attempt
Republican delegates and infect them and
this this is on me this isn't it isn't
just some some freak right wing website
this is something that's actually on the
Republican National Committee website
and that goes hand in hand with the
warning that appeared in the other daily
news earlier this week that 50 of the
nation's so-called leading anarchists
are in town and ready to cause trouble
but they've actually been here all year
in coffee shops in the lower east side
trying to sell their poetry to people I
mean there i mean the the idea that
there's something incredibly dangerous
happening here is just absurd and it's
being played up for obvious reasons and
i'm surprised it's not more of an issue
ira stoll your paper is running out
is already out of date because of the
bicycle protest last night but you've
started a feature this week called the
arrest o meter which as you point to
press on I guess Thursday night Friday
night for this one would this week
thursday night Thursday night was at 15
a lot bigger number at this point
because of as I mentioned the big
protest with bicyclists last night but
answer the caller's question if you
would yeah well I don't think it's
exactly right to say that none of these
protesters have any connection to the
kerry campaign or the democratic party
this morning actually there will be a
big protest from an abortion rights
group but i think it's either Planned
Parenthood or neigh ow which is a you
know a core constituency group of the
Democratic Party and send out sent a lot
of delegates to Boston not course not
every crazy naked person you see getting
arrested is a you know a part of the
kerry campaign but there are a lot of
people who will be voting for John Kerry
who will be in the streets this week and
some of them probably her already have
been arrested and you know I think I
think the Democrats as part of the
climate of hatred of President Bush you
know Michael Moore of fahrenheit 911 was
at the Democratic convention he was
cheered and a lot of that really hateful
rhetoric has an effect on people all of
our misery supporter of President Bush
go ahead well my only comment is that
you know the Democrats have been naked
all the time thank you very much the
Democrats have been naked all the time
he's playing up your report on the naked
protesters well he's at clearly after
your job because he likes a little
comedy with this what are you finding
funny interesting humorous about this
that you've you said you want to take it
from a perspective of adding a little
humor to the disco we find the entire
thing funny and actually that's what
we're doing we're doing
in our cover story on Tuesday is a
thousand things to aid about the
convention and at first we thought that
that it was going to be hard to fill all
those slots but actually it looks like
we're gonna have to edit out quite a lot
just because there are so many things
about this this this convention that are
that are so ridiculous a lot of the
protests are are so absurd and then of
course the Republican lineup is also
ridiculous so I mean give you an example
of some of the the dangerous protests
are going to be happening there's an
anti bush water gun fight tomorrow I
think it is or the next day there are
people who are going to be shooting a
gigantic fake gun into the sky in order
to to slay the repressed sexual energy
of the Republican delegates you know I
mean this this kind of stuff is going on
and you know it's seems like every third
protester has a terrible idea to draw
attention to himself so that's it's
really rich comic material ira stoll
we've seen a lot of money stories in the
paper today about how much this
convention is costing the estimates on
security alone are in the range of 60
million to 70 million dollars we learned
that the federal government is sending
the city 50 million dollars to help pay
for security costs let me ask you a
question why is that a is that a useful
amount of money for all the people
watching this program in Texas Kentucky
that sort of thing why should they pay
for this convention in New York City
well a lot of their senators and
congressmen are coming in New York this
week and they need to be protected from
these protesters they need to be
protected from the threat of a terrorist
attack that's that's these conventions
have to be somewhere they did the same
thing for Boston when the Democrats went
there a lot of these officials a
particularly the President the Vice
President are protected wherever they go
around the country by the Secret Service
and
this is this is just in a post-911 era
the cost of having a national political
convention where are you on the on the
perennial quadrennial debate about
whether or not conventions should happen
anymore well I think it's a useful
opportunity to get people's attention I
a lot of people aren't tuning in during
the summer to politics they're watching
the Olympics or they're they're on
vacation with their friends and this is
a way in addition to the debates which
will be happening between now and
November for people who may not have
been watching in Iowa or New Hampshire
during the primaries to to get a sense
of what the message is of the major
political parties and the candidates
Matt Taibbi are they useful I think they
probably would be useful if either the
parties or the media we're interested in
educating the public a little bit about
the issues that are going on but
actually despite that monumental amount
of coverage that goes on for the next
four or five days we won't hear anything
about what the clear skies act is we
won't hear anything about about any of
Bush's policies in depth what the hell
the No Child Left Behind Act actually
works what the WTO is what the
president's trade policies are none of
these things are going to be covered in
any kind of detail they're going to be
brushed over and the candidates
themselves aren't going to be spending
any time on them either and so as a
result we just end up looking at a whole
bunch of people who are going to be
mouthing stupid platitudes of the camera
and then when it's all over people don't
know any more than they did before so I
mean if if it attracts their attention
that's one thing but we don't really do
anything with that attention during this
period of time Lubbock Texas good
morning supporter of Senator Kerry hi
folks I hope y'all are doing good today
hello can you hear me yes sir no I
wanted to give you just a couple of
quick things from West Texas some some
thoughts one is I grew up in here about
the same time as as George Bush I was an
immigrant also i moved from up north i
was born in oklahoma and moved to texas
when I was five I think George came from
a little further north but I won't hold
that against him
uh when he grew up in the 60s he was
either one of two things he was either a
cat daddy or a goat roper and I'll
assure you I'd be real surprised if he
was a goat roper I would imagine he was
a cat daddy that was a city kid a goat
roper was a guy that grew up ranching
and knew how to rope a goat and that's
really a thing that kids in the country
did the other thing I've got for you
guys that I'm Gladish newspaper guys
please investigate why John Kerry has
250 fellow sailors in an organization
against him but I can't seem to spot one
fella National Guard pilot that flew
with John with George Bush are any
member of his flight crew I brought this
up on c-span about six weeks ago it's
not one single member of his flight crew
that that maintained that airplane are
those airplanes which he was supposed to
have flown there ought to be one or two
people stepping forward and I'd like to
have them do it to tell about the days
they spent getting George Bush's
airplane ready to fly the only other
thing is that ranch has no cattle really
bothers me thanks guys thanks to the
call the debate over vietnam war service
i'm wondering how it seems to both of
you for whom vietnam is really something
from the history books matt taibbi watch
a star moe well I think this whole
debate over John Kerry Swift Boat
service it's straight out of the
manchurian candidate if you remember
that scene where Angela Lansbury says to
her husband you know they're not saying
are they're communists in the Congress
they're saying how many communists are
there in Congress when she starts making
charges that there are 57 communist
card-carrying communists in Congress I
mean the whole point is we have this
ridiculous debate over what John Kerry
did or did not do in Vietnam and it's
just taking all the attention away from
from for instance what George Bush was
doing during that time well that was the
caller's exact point who were said we're
not not really focusing on george w
bush's the announcer and i think i just
want to answer his question the reason
why some none of those people have come
forward yet i really doubt that they get
together for reunions to celebrate the
time that they were dodging the draft
during during
during Vietnam those people were working
in air force bases a backpack in the
early 70s I don't think they had the
same kind of bond that people who
actually went to vietnam had ira stoll
well wait a minute i mean serving in the
air force national guard is not dodging
the draft those people were flying
dangerous airplanes and and they were
serving the country so i think i think
there's a distinction i think that short
leash if george bush wasn't a wealthy
son of a congressman that you that he
would have gotten that deferment well
let's talk about Bill Clinton new you
know wrote wrote letters and pulls all
kinds of strings and went to Oxford that
doesn't seem to be a problem for a lot
of these people who are now attacking
president bush for serving his country
well I think the differences to the
Democrats weren't charging it their
opponents were unpatriotic and unfit for
to leave the country military well the
difference with John Kerry is that he
made his service in Vietnam the
centerpiece of his agenda at the of his
pitch at the Boston Convention if he
doesn't people want people to talk about
it you know why did he have all these
Vietnam buddies introduce him at the
convention there so agree with you there
there's a new entry into this debate
over Vietnam service this is in today's
New York Times Ben Barnes former Speaker
of Texas House who said he got George W
Bush the net into the National Guard in
1968 told an audience of John Kerry
supporters in austin on may 27th that he
was ashamed of his role quote i walked
through the Vietnam Memorial the other
day mr. Barnes said according to a video
clip posted on the internet this summer
and I looked at the names of people who
died in Vietnam and I became more
ashamed of myself than I've ever been
because the worst thing I did was get a
lot of wealthy supporters and a lot of
people who had family names of
importance into the guard and I'm very
sorry about that and I apologize to you
and the voters of Texas that's the quote
a 45 second video of his remarks which
were not reported at the time was posted
jun 25th on a website Austin for Kari
com that crashed on friday from overuse
after Jim more in Austin author of books
on mr. Bush sent out email messages
calling attention to it the video was
then shifted to another site which is
all numbers and if folks are interested
it's 69 dot 59
167 dot 1607 that's pretty complicated
i'll do it one more time 69 dot 59 167
dot 1607 and mr. Barnes a Democrat did
not return calls for comment any
reaction well look what we've been
saying at the New York Sun is that and
what most of the candidates have been
saying is that this election is is about
what the president or the person who
would be president is going to do in the
next four years now what about that they
did 20 or 30 years ago and look there's
a war right now just like there was in
Vietnam and and the question is who's
going to be the best person to lead
America and this war on on terrorism and
and you know you can look at what
President Bush has done these last four
years in Iraq and Afghanistan you can
look at the way senator Kerry has spoken
and voted on these issues and and what
what he says he's going to do and you
can make your decisions you know what
these guys did when they were 20 years
old is probably not the most important
thing in making those decisions well I
think it's relevant in the case of the
Bush administration that so many of the
people who are making their policy and
deciding whether or not to go into Iraq
for instance didn't serve in the
military I mean I think that's the
relevant issue if you want it obviously
it's not really important what kind of a
person a person was when he was 20 when
he's going to be running the country
when he's 55 or 60 the difference is
that people who have some experience
with war probably are going to be more
reluctant to send people into battle
than then somebody who's actually been
there and I think we definitely saw that
with the Iraq war I mean it was an
absolutely pointless war and all these
people who had never served with a one
soon push for Louisville Kentucky good
morning welcome to our program from New
York good morning I've been watching
programs from cbn news on 700 club in
WorldNetDaily and they show convincing
evidence of truckloads of supposed
weapons of mass destruction leaving Iraq
and going into Syria and they've also
reported that the Jordanian intelligence
and government confirmed that and I
wonder why that has never gotten any air
kind
I'm in the mainstream media like to get
your thoughts on that please thank you
very much shower stall well we've been
writing about that quite a bit in the
New York Sun and it's not just the
evidence that the weapons were were
taken to Syria actually in Iraq and that
the inspectors have testified before
Congress there was a vial of toxic
biological material that was in the home
of an Iraqi biological weapons scientist
you have to wonder what he was doing
bringing that stuff home other than
concealing it there have been shells
found with chemical weapons in them that
American officials have verified now
about a dozen of them and you know I
think as especially as it gets closer to
november i think the bush administration
is going to be coming forward more
aggressively to talk about that we've
certainly been focusing on it in the New
York Sun and that's why you know I
actually think Matt is wrong when he
says the Iraq war was pointless there
are a lot of people in Iraq who now have
newspapers they have different
newspapers with different opinions they
have political parties it's not perfect
over there but it's a lot better than it
was when Saddam was in power and Saddam
was was paying suicide bombers in Israel
15,000 $25,000 the families of them you
know I think we're a lot better off well
I mean for to answer the caller's
question of course there were weapons of
mass destruction in Iraq because we sold
them to them I mean the anthrax in
botulinum toxin have been in Iraq for 15
years if they're not there anymore it
might not be there anymore but it could
be after repeated sanctions and
inspections in the last 10 years but
even if they are there which they
probably aren't in great quantities it
doesn't matter it's still a pointless
war I mean you don't go to war against
somebody unless it's absolutely an
intimate imminent threat to your own
country and Iraq wasn't it clearly
wasn't even a threat to the other
countries in the region anymore and
it's just it's a wrong use of military
force and I think it's it's irrelevant
whether they discover something between
now and the election I expect them to
but it doesn't doesn't make a difference
The Times has twin headlines on the
front page today about the end of the
standoff in Najaf Alec's parents and
reporting from mushaf after the siege
the city of ruins is it's dead rotting
testimony to ferocity of three week
fight and Dexter Filkins also filing out
of Najaf insurgents quit mosque and is
off after peace deal uneasy and a
standoff rebel clerics followers failed
to give up guns and civilians pouring
you can see lots of news coverage of
this on the other television stations
Philadelphia's next a supporter of
Senator Kerry you're on the washington
journal morning folks yeah listening at
this conversation here of course they're
listening to quote unquote newscast it
was as what you if you can if you can
consider what you hear on Fox and
everything else has news and reading the
newspapers here in Philadelphia and and
listening most of all listening to what
the candidates have to say you know it
is clear that politics in the u.s. is so
bearing on the facts they're so shallow
and that time is really infantile you
know they're bad we're good and and it's
just it it's like not one of these
candidates has ever and not only with
the selection but all pass elections now
one of these candidates has mentioned
over five hundred and thirty five
thousand homes that are waiting to be
foreclosed on in the US here in
Philadelphia we had seven hundred homes
for foreclosed upon now counting the
hundreds that are lying in wait to be
foreclosed upon nothing has been
mentioned about the homeless or or ever
has been mentioned about the homeless
eating out a trashcan sleeping old steam
vents and nothing has been that ever
talked about with the David no matter up
to a 14,000 people making below below
poverty wages not counting the people
are making poverty wages it's just that
when it comes to it you know it just
seems like we are so good this country
is so good finding new ways to
kill to go to war and finding new ways
to kill but we're so incompetent to make
life good you know it may I ask you a
question let me move from your
discussion of the issues which I'll
throw to our guests to your first
comment about the state of dialogue on
national politics is there ever been a
time in your life time that that you
think it's been more substantive ended
up as far as in this case you think no
the national national debate in
political elections I've you know the
only people that I've ever heard bring
up some of these facts are independent
candidate I candidate ie Ralph later
that is considered it seems like when
people or come from independent parties
a grassroots parties they talk about
these they talk about the real issues
and it seems like people in this country
do not want to talk about the real
issues because they were afraid of the
truth thanks very much ira stoll the two
twin issues there yeah well you know I
don't think it's exactly a hundred
percent accurate to say that those
issues aren't getting aired as part of
the debate senator Kerry on Thursday
when the new census report out on
poverty data came out issued a statement
on the poverty issue we saw the poverty
rate rise slightly for 2003 according to
these new census numbers and as you
pointed out Dennis Kucinich is actually
a member of the Democratic Party took
part in at least a dozen debates with
the other Democratic presidential
candidates Ralph Nader is going to be on
a fair number of ballots certainly gets
heard to some degree I think should be
included in the debates you know the the
fact that these candidates haven't been
able to attract a majority support in
this country may be a sign that these
issues which you see is important may
not be as important to
a large number of American voters I
think the reason that they keep the
candidates do it is because it's easy
and and because most there isn't a large
difference ideologically between the two
parties so as a result that they focus
on minutia and and bashing each other
because that's the only way that they
can demonstrate a difference between
each other running up to the election i
think the candidates mostly agree on
most of the key issues about free trade
about most economic issues and so what
we get is we get swift boat veterans on
one side and gay marriage on the other
side and these are the issues that take
up all of our time but i think it's
really gotten worse in the age of the
24-hour news cycle with with cable
because it just places such an emphasis
on the periodic immediate update so what
we get is some kind of a story that's
running and that has constant reactions
and re reactions in the press so we have
a charge about the swift boat veterans
and then we have an answer about the
swift boat veterans and then we have we
cut to a lorry hacking update and then
we cut to the Laci Peterson trial update
and then we go back to the Swift Boat
because there's something new there I
mean it's just that the format just
isn't conducive to elect the exploration
of what's going on with you know home
lending or the homeless or the
environment or anything like that it's
just not conducive to people actually
digesting and understanding the issues
so this is the first national election
post mccain-feingold I want to ask you
both about money and politics there's a
story in today's times Jodi well Goran
is the author on this and talks about
how senator Kerry and I'm shows similar
stories from the other campaign who has
accepted the 75 million dollars in
public financing for the fall campaign
is nonetheless out raising money and
because he has been legally a barred
from collecting checks of up to two
thousand dollars for his campaign
because he's taking the public money he
has been headlining fundraising events
where donors pump up to twenty seven
thousand dollars each and to the carrie
edwards victory fund which goes mainly
to the party's coffers so it's soft
money as opposed to hard but also
subsidizes the legal and accounting work
for the campaign what are your thoughts
about money in this year's campaign
well what we've been saying at the New
York Sun is that these restrictions on
money and politics should have been
ruled unconstitutional by the Supreme
Court because there are bridgeman of the
First Amendment guarantees of freedom of
speech freedom of the press is a very
fine line particularly with the blurring
of media you know what constitutes a
expenditure and what constitutes a
contribution if people pay to publish a
book by the swift swift boat veterans
for truth their publishers I mean it's
freedom of the press whereas if you pay
for a television commercial by the swift
boat veterans for truth that's regulated
by the government you have to disclose
who the donors are or you have to at
least file a tax return saying how much
you spent you know people are going to
spend money in politics i think more
more spending more speech is good it
ends up clarifying the issues for people
and and it if if it doesn't sway votes
then it probably wasn't a very important
issue so you know I think we're seeing
with these new ways of spending money
like what senator Kerry is doing the
so-called 527 groups the folly of trying
to make laws that it's like trying to
make laws that prevent water from
running downhill well I agree that
people are always going to be
contributing to to political campaigns
but I'd like to see it restricted the
people i mean i think people seem to
forget that it wasn't always true that
bet companies and business organizations
and lobbying groups could pay for
commercials and pay for 527s or any
other kind of political activity it
wasn't until the early 70s at the
Supreme Court ruled that corporations
had Fourteenth Amendment rights which
made them people who are allowed to have
the same First Amendment rights that
individuals do and they also ruled that
money was speech that companies could do
this so I'd like to see the the playing
field at least taken back to the level
of human beings
instead of making it also possible for
corporations and companies to donate to
the political process because it wasn't
always true in the United States and it
seems to me that it was a better system
before we had that well sound Michigan
good morning to you yes good morning you
gave that the Democrat Carrie supporters
a little bit of time so I hope you give
me some time to that yammering idiot I'd
like to say we never hear about the
homeless unless there's a Republican
administration in office and if you want
to know about the homeless and the poor
read your Bible the poor ye always have
with ye okay secondly as far as the
comparisons between Vietnam the war
there and Iraq the only comparison I can
see is that Republican administration
has to come in and clean up what a
previous Democratic administration the
mess that they've made and that's what's
happening now for years eight years to
be precise of the Clinton administration
terrorism and these maniacs from the
Muslim world were virtually ignored and
acted like they were simply common
criminals when you know people have been
warning us for years and years even
beyond the Clinton administration that
this kind of thing was coming these
people are intent on world domination
they hate our guts they want to kill as
many Americans as possible and that's
the point that's what we're up against
that's what we are facing and these
clowns in New York if I were a
millionaire every cop that cracked
opened the head of a protester would get
a thousand dollars thank you Matt tiny
I just don't even know what to say to a
person like that you know if he if he
really thinks that just just to take one
small specific thing he's upset that the
Democrats created a mess in Vietnam
which I agree with him about because
they started a war and in this case he's
upset with the Democrats because they
didn't start a war so I mean I don't I
don't even understand that I it's it's
uh you know this is this whole business
about ping being being happy that the
police might crack somebody over the
head it's it's just I don't know it's
just it's absurd mistral well I agree
that you know the police like the
protesters should obey the laws I do
agree that that it was a problem that
response to terrorism before September
11th and the 911 Commission report made
that clear we have been talking about it
in the New York Sun how the sandy Berger
President Clinton's national security
adviser was given four chances to attack
al Qaeda and Osama bin Laden
preemptively he decided not to do it but
I also think you know in fairness is not
just the Clinton administration that
that didn't act i mean the bush
administration the firt during the first
Iraq war didn't go all the way and
remove Saddam Hussein from power and if
if they had then the current Bush
administration might not have to be
cleaning up that mess let me go back to
the homeless issue which now to callers
have called about you suggested the time
that perhaps that the reason wasn't
addressed by campaigns is because it's
not on the minds of voters I want to ask
because your weekend edition of the new
york sun gives its lead story to the
u.s. poverty rate edging upward
according to census data obviously your
page one editor thought it was critical
for your readership to know about so
square that with the your thoughts in
the last two callers well that paper
came out after that statement by center
carry that i mentioned
and trying to make a big deal out of
this new census data and the census data
particularly for a New York audience
which the New York Sun tries to aim at
it is interesting I mean Bronx one of
the counties in New York is the third
poorest County in the whole country and
the statistics show that it's actually
sort of hard to distinguish it from the
most poor county in the country and you
know we're here in Manhattan in the
middle of incredible wealth on upper
east side and you know just a few blocks
away in the Bronx we've got this
incredible poverty so you know I think
it is something that we need new yorkers
see on a regular basis we've seen
footage on television in the past week
of homeless people from around Madison
Square Garden being being cleared out
now they're going to be poor people as
that the caller who made reference to
the Bible mentioned there always have
been and there probably isn't much that
the government can do to prevent there
being some poverty but what the Bush
administration has been talking about is
is faith based aid to the poor where the
government can help some of these
religious charities that run soup
kitchens and have been actually some of
the most effective ways along with
welfare reform of getting people out of
poverty and into work that pays we
comment from you well i mean first of
all the faith-based programs they don't
add any money to two programs for the
poor it just makes it possible for
religious charities to to administer
some of those programs so it isn't like
there's an increased emphasis on on
helping out the poor financially it's
just it's a shift in tactics so
burlington vermont good morning good
morning um I just want to say that the
strongest strongest warning that any
executive branch ever got regarding
terror
was the the advice that the Bush
administration got in January of 2001
from the Clinton outgoing Clinton
administration and they did absolutely
nothing about it for nine months and we
had 911 and I want to say that it is
just I'm so sick of hearing it said that
Clinton's military record was of no
concern to the Democrats Clinton did not
well certain surgical bombings and and
other things there was the fiasco and
now in Somalia and some other things we
were not embarked upon a major
occupation of a huge Middle Eastern
nation with a huge number of troops and
a back door draft and a draft coming it
was perfectly valid for for the
Democrats to put carries heroic military
service in the forefront to have the alt
both the officers present the generals
and other officers present to endorse
him and his uh is uh brothers and arms
from from his Swift Boat experience um I
also want to say that it has become so
conflated the Afghanistan and Iraq Wars
that it is can become completely
forgotten that centre-left Democrats
were in full support of surgical
military action immediately following
911 I didn't know why Bush was sitting
on his hands and why we waited until
November to do something I don't know if
Afghanistan I don't have any connection
to the intelligence community so I don't
know if Afghanistan was the right target
but centre-left Democrats were in full
support as was the world as was Western
Europe in full support of us going into
Afghanistan because we saw it as the
appropriate military
Iraq is another matter and we all I
could talk and talk and talk we all know
what kind of hooey Iraq is and I just
like to hear your gentleman's comments
thanks very much well a lot of
centre-left Democrats voted to authorize
President Bush to use force in Iraq New
York's two senators Hillary Clinton and
Charles Schumer senator Kerry senator
Lieberman so you know I think if they
thought it was who we they wouldn't have
voted to authorize President Bush to do
it when they spoke about it on the
Senate floor they talked about the
attack on September 11th and what that
meant for New York and how we couldn't
risk that happening again you know as
far as Carey's military experience
making him fit to be commander in chief
now you know history shows that people
who had excellent war experience like
Ulysses Grant were not so good
presidents and some Americans who didn't
have wartime experience like Abraham
Lincoln were excellent wartime
presidents so I don't I don't think it's
it's a good idea to make military
experience a prerequisite for serving as
president of the United States even in
wartime first I think I'd like to
address the the caller's mention of the
warning the President Bush got in
January of 2001 I i think this this
whole idea that somehow President Bush
should be held accountable because he
failed to prevent these people from
hijacking and doing this extraordinarily
unpredictable thing that they did is
absurd and I think that probably both
sides should refrain from doing and I
mean the whole point of terrorism that
is it is that it's almost impossible to
stop no matter how much money you throw
at it and how much and how
forcefully you oppose it militarily
abroad it's just it's just not that easy
to stop a few determined individuals
from destroying a whole lot of property
or people and I think as somebody who's
an opponent of George Bush I get really
tired of hearing Democrats carp on on
this particular issue it's I think it's
it's irresponsible want to say thanks to
both of you